did you end up meeting new friends did
you sit at a fun table a lot of people
you meet a lot of people there was one
in particular that I was very very happy
to meet yeah and this is a key kiwan
yeah how did you meet him at first I met
him I was at the
governor's uh ball Y and I didn't know
who he was and he asked me for a selfie
and my boyfriend saw the selfie and he
was like oh my God you met key and I'm
like yeah he's like his data from The
Goonies and I'm like what in Cuba they
would play The Goonies all the time on
TV like this was one of my favorite
movies ever this selfie was so horrible
I'm so serious because I'm like I saw
him and I was like I ran to him and I
was like I need a selfie with you here's
the one that he took when you didn't
really recognize him and then here's the
one after you went up to him you're like
oh yeah